the New York Times slams everyone on the
right is gateway to the alt-right
Pinterest allegedly cracks down on
pro-lifers and Trump's tariffs may be
turning up roses I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show I swear I leave for
a Jewish holiday in every single time I
leave for a Jewish holiday the New York
Times attacks me I don't know what it is
about Jewish holidays in the New York
Times I mean I have an indicator but
nonetheless we will get to that in just
one second first some things in life are
just uncomfortable to talk about sex is
one of those things but sex is also one
of the more important things in life
especially within the context of a
healthy marriage
studies show that 70% of dudes who
experience erectile dysfunction don't
actually get treated for it for just
that reason it's pretty awkward to
discuss but sometimes things just don't
work the way they are supposed to that's
not something to be ashamed about just
like other health problems aren't
anything to be ashamed about that's what
our friends at Roman come in thankfully
Roman created an easy way to get checked
out by a doctor and get treated for IDI
online with Roman you can get medical
care for IDI if appropriate from the
comfort and privacy of your own home you
can handle everything online in a
convenient discreet manner getting
started is simple just go to get Roman
comm slash Ben and complete an online
visit if the doctor decides that
treatment will be appropriate they can
then prescribe genuine medication that
can be delivered in discreet packaging
direct your door with free two-day
shipping dudes go talk to the doctor
he can be tough to tackle but it's
really important to get it checked out
just like any other health problem just
go get it checked out right now go to
get Roman comm slash Ben get a free
online visit and free 2-day shipping
that is get Roman comm slash Ben for a
free visit to get started that's get
Roman comm slash Ben okay so as I say I
leave for a Jewish holiday and every
time I do all hell breaks loose I
remember a couple of years ago there's a
Jewish holiday and I come back from the
Jewish holiday and there's been an
entire op IDI in the New York Times
about how I'm a terrible person and then
I left I think just last year for a
Jewish holiday and I come back and
there's a New York Times article about
how then about how we here at Ailey wire
are about it's pretty much every Jewish
holiday like they schedule it out that
way so that I have a really really
wonderful time coming back from the
Jewish holiday opening my computer and
seeing what stupidity has taken place
well this week's stupidity comes
courtesy of the New York Times yet again
apparently there was an article and the
article I guess was on the cover of the
York Times Sunday edition ah I guess it
was it was a Saturday article online it
was a Sunday edition front-page article
on Sunday and the article is titled the
making of a YouTube radical and it was
basically a story about a Rando the
randoms in the randos name is Caleb Cain
and it's all about his supposed
radicalization now what's hilarious
about the article is that the article
talks about him being quote/unquote
radicalized he was never a member the
alt-right
he wasn't a white supremacist he
considered himself a trad con meeting a
traditional conservative until he moved
over to the left so in other words he
became a conservative by listening to
YouTube videos and they called him a
YouTube radical the graphic that they
put up was a bunch of different kind of
images of different YouTube videos but
they lumped together a bunch of YouTube
videos that are completely dissimilar so
there is a picture of me there I'm not
mentioned one time in the entire article
by the way there's a picture of me and
then there's pictures of people like
stefan molyneux who has some borderline
white supremacist race theories at the
very mildest that's the mildest way to
discover to describe it you have people
like Alex Jones you have people like
Paul Joseph Watson you have folks like
milo gianopolous and then you know like
Milton Friedman was in this mashup like
Milton Friedman so Milton Friedman and I
are in the same category as milo
gianopolous and like Richard Spencer
according to this particular this
particular graphic on the cover of the
New York Times and the article itself is
incredibly stupid the article itself is
basically about how he watched some
videos and let him to other videos which
led him to other videos which led him to
become a trad Khan and then people were
upset at him becoming a trad Khan so
then he became not a trad Khan anymore
that's the entire article it's thousands
of words long
thousands words so a couple of things to
note number one there's a full-on
campaign by the left media at this point
from the Washington Post
to the New York Times from NBC to Media
Matters and I count media matters as
part of the left media infrastructure
any publication that calls media matters
a watchdog group you can tell is on the
side of media matters there is this
overt effort now on the part of all of
these publications to suggest that the
tech companies are basically leading
people down the rabbit hole of all trite
white supremacist content by even
allowing mainstream conservative content
that's the goal here
some lump in everybody who's a
mainstream conservative with people who
are alright and then suggest that if you
watch mainstream conservative contents
then inevitably you will be led down
this rabbit hole now this is absurd and
bizarre there are legitimately hundreds
of thousands of people who listen to the
show every day who are not even on the
political right there are hundreds of
thousands of people who are on the
political right and believe that the
alt-right is evil just as I do but
according to the New York Times in the
Washington Post and all of these other
outlets basically if you're on the right
you're going to slide gradually into
white supremacism so long as you engage
on YouTube now the reason they are
directing this at YouTube is because
they are hoping to use YouTube in order
to quash conservative viewpoints they
understand that there are certain shared
fora where people post their views
Facebook YouTube Twitter all the rest of
those Pinterest and then what they're
hoping to do they understand
conservatives aren't going to stop
talking so what they hope to do is make
conservative speech so ridiculously
outside the Overton Window that all of
these shared platforms have to shut it
down and they're hoping to do this in
advance for the 2020 election the timing
is not a mistake here it is not a
coincidence here ever since the left
decided that Hillary Clinton had
illegitimately lost the 2016 election
and that she really won ever since that
they've been looking for a scapegoat Ana
scapegoat that is the most convenient
for them are the tech companies and by
attacking the tech companies with the
left hopes to do is cause the tech
companies to curb the content they allow
on their platforms in advance of 2020 so
the argument they are making is that the
tech platforms didn't do enough to shut
down the nefarious loose keys and
therefore they have to shut down
everybody on the right in advance of
2020 or at least curb their reach
or at least elevated quote-unquote
authoritative voices so here's what this
New York Times idiotic piece says they
say caleb kane pulled the glock pistol
from his waistband took out the magazine
and casually tossed both onto the
kitchen counter i bought it the day
after i got death threats he said the
threats mister can't explain him from
right-wing trolls in response to a video
he had posted on youtube a few days
earlier in the video he told the story
of how as a liberal college dropout
struggling to find his place in the
world he'd gotten sucked into a vortex
of far-right politics on youtube
I fell down the alt-right rabbit hole he
said in the video so a couple of things
right off the bat number one he didn't
actually he was so crazily right-wing he
didn't even own a gun until he became a
leftist again and then talked about it
on YouTube
mr. Cain 26 recently swore off the
alt-right nearly five years after
discovering it and has become a vocal
critic of the movement well welcome sir
welcome enjoy the party
your little late pal he is scarred by
his experience of being radicalized by
what he calls the decentralized cult of
far-right YouTube personalities who
convinced him that Western civilization
was under threat from Muslim immigrants
and cultural Marxists that innate IQ
differences explained racial disparities
and that feminism was a dangerous
ideology I love how he lumps all of
those things together so if you say that
third wave feminism is a dangerous
ideology which it is apparently that is
in the same box as believing that innate
IQ differences are entirely to blame for
racial disparities apparently they're
all the same so you see even here what
the New York Times is doing they're
taking mainstream conservative ideas
like third wave feminism is a bad idea
and dangerous for a civilization and
they're lumping that together with the
racist idea that all disparities are
attributable to innate biological
difference between people in different
racial groups they're just lumping those
two together like that's not a problem
I just kept falling deeper and deeper
into this and it appealed to me because
it made me feel a sense of belonging he
said I was brainwashed now why in the
world is this guy mr. Cain what Caleb
Cain will I see the center of a New York
Times front page story because it
supports the narrative it's a piece of
anecdotal data that supports the
left-wing narrative that everybody who's
in the alt-right originally started as a
member of the mainstream conservative
movement and then was radicalized by
YouTube and this is why we have to
pressure YouTube into shutting down
steven crowder or shutting down ben
shapiro or shutting down glenn beck or
shutting down mark levin or shutting
down anybody who is on the right over
years of reporting on internet culture
says this New York Times reporter I've
heard countless versions of mr. Kane's
story a nameless young man usually white
frequently interested in videogames
visits YouTube looking for direction or
distraction and is seduced by a
community of far right creators some
young men discover far-right videos by
accident while others seek them out some
travel all the way to neo nazism while
others stop at milder forms of bigotry
the common thread in many of these
stories is YouTube and its
recommendation algorithm well there's
another common thread which is that when
dispossessed young men go looking for
content that appeals to them they might
be able to find the content that appeals
to them because they are dispossessed
young men in other words these are human
beings who are created with the capacity
for free will
and this means they get to choose which
videos they access and which videos they
believe but according to youtube if you
watch a video of me ripping the
alt-right which is like every other
video of me online if you watch a video
of me ripping the alt-right this
inevitably leads you to the outright
this is how you end up at the idiotic
media coverage of a couple weeks ago
where the media tried to blame me for an
attack on a synagogue which is the most
asinine contention I could possibly
imagine but the New York Times continues
the radicalization of young men is
driven by a complex stew of emotional
economic and political elements many
have nothing to do with social media but
and it's the but that matters here
critics an independent researcher say
YouTube has inadvertently created a
dangerous on-ramp to extremism by
combining two things a business model
that rewards provocative videos with
exposure and advertising dollars and an
algorithm that guides users on
personalized paths meant to keep them
glued to their screens
it's YouTube's fault its YouTube's fault
Tristan Harris former design ethicist at
Google by the way if you are designed
ethicist this should answer the question
as to whether these big tech companies
are designing the algorithms with
certain values in mind they've been
saying all along no no they're just
following the traffic they actually had
a position called the design ethicist
at Google Tristan Harris says if I'm
YouTube and I want you to watch more I'm
always going to steer you toward
crazytown weird that no one on the left
has ever suggested that YouTube should
maybe disassociate from say The Young
Turks on the left no one has ever
suggested that YouTube disassociate from
far-left views weird odd because it
turns out that some people have been
radicalized by those sorts of videos as
well in recent years social media
platforms have grappled with the growth
of extremism on their services says the
New York Times many platforms have
barred a handful of far-right
influencers and conspiracy theorists
including Alex Jones of tech of Infowars
and tech companies have taken steps to
limit the spread of political
misinformation YouTube whose rules
prohibited hate speech and harassment
took a more lays a fair approach to
enforcement for years and this is where
the New York Times is trying to push
there are times is trying to push by
saying that this lays a fair approach
has been a complete failure and is
causing people to be radicalized because
radicalization never happened before the
YouTube algorithm and because YouTube
has the temerity to leave conservative
views on their platform what's funny
about this is they're really not
YouTube's algorithm in the end this
article as you will see does not blame
YouTube's algorithm and suggests that
the algorithm needs to be changed so
that it doesn't benefit some of the
fringe views instead they basically
argue that YouTube should crackdown on
mainstream conservative views because
there's no difference between mainstream
conservatism and far-right alt-right
views we'll get to more of that in just
one second first we need to talk about
your freedoms they are in fact in danger
you hear me talk all the time on the
show about the growing attacks on
religious freedom and freedom of speech
you can see today's show is all about
the attack on the principled nature of
freedom of speech and we've talked
repeatedly on the show about the attacks
on religious freedom that come as a
consequence of the radical growth of
government well now's a great time tell
people like baron el Stutzman a small
business owner floral floral artist and
grandmother who is sued by her States
government and the ACLU for simply
declining to create custom floral art
celebrating and events that conflicted
with her Christian beliefs we had baron
el on our radio show last week she could
lose her business her home and her life
savings if she loses this is why
Alliance defending freedom exists ATF
provides free legal services to
marinelle and others whose freedoms are
under assault ATF will ask the US
Supreme Court to hear her case but ATF
cannot do that without your help because
ATF relies on donations to fight for
your freedom if this attack can happen
to someone like Barron oh it can happen
to somebody like you as well the left
does not care about basic free speech
standards and liberals the left will you
fight for Barron I'll protect your
freedom please give generously all
donations are in fact tax-deductible and
if you donate 75 bucks an above you'll
receive an exclusive free speech shirt
go to ADF Legal org slash pens to donate
right now I love ATF to do amazing work
they really are a great organization go
check them out right now ATF legal dot
org slash ban that's ATF legal org slash
ban when you give 75 bucks or above you
get an exclusive free speech shirt
that's ATF illegal org slash ban okay so
this New York Times piece which again
lumps in everybody on the right
continues with two billion monthly
active users uploading more than 500
hours of video every minute YouTube's
traffic is estimated to be the second
highest of any website behind only
google.com according to Pew Research
Center 94% of Americans aged 18 to 24
use YouTube a higher percentage than for
any other online service like many other
Silicon Valley companies YouTube is
outwardly liberal in its corporate
policies it floated sponsors floats in
LGBT pride parades its chief executive
endorsed Hillary Clinton
in reality YouTube has been a godsend
for Hyper partisans on all sides weird
weird that you say this and then the
entire articles about the right odd very
odd I can't imagine why the New York
Times would do that and then they say I
love this it has also been a useful
recruiting tool for far-right extremist
groups Bell Inc at an investigative news
site analyzed messages from far-right
chat rooms and found that YouTube but
was cited as the most frequent cause of
members red pilling an internet slang
term from converting to far-right
beliefs
well since you just said that 94% of
people aged 18 to 24 watch YouTube I can
imagine that's true
this is like saying guess what helps
people change their viewpoint television
woo television it's the televisions
fault a European research group Vox Paul
conducted a separate analysis of 30,000
Twitter accounts affiliated with the
alt-right it found the accounts linked
to YouTube more often than to any other
site because it's the most linked
psyched on the Internet that would
probably be it Becca Lewis who runs a
garbage study for data and society a
study that was so dumb that they
basically had to retract their own
findings ok this study basically
suggested a 7 degrees of separation was
it was six degrees of Kevin Bacon but
with politics it was basically like ok
so Dave Rubin interviewed me and I have
interviewed steven crowder and steven
crowder has interviewed stefan molyneux
therefore dave rubin and dave rubin also
once interviewed like Mike Gatto the
Democratic Assemblyman therefore Mike
Gatto is linked to stefan molyneux
they're all the same it's it's just it's
ridiculous that was her idiotic study
she says youtube has been able to fly
under the radar because until recently
no one thought of it as a place where
radicalization is happening but it's
where young people are getting their
information and entertainment it's a
space where creators are broadcasting
political content that at times is
overtly white supremacists okay then the
article gets back to this this mr. Kane
this Caleb Kane who's a very very
important human I visited mr. Kane in
West Virginia after seeing his YouTube
video denouncing the far-right we spent
hours discussing his radicalization to
back up his recollections he downloaded
and sent me his entire YouTube history
evolved with more than 12,000 videos and
more than 2,500 search queries datings
to 2015 okay right there they should
have ended the article okay if you've
watched more than 12,000 videos and more
than 2,500 search queries on YouTube
dating back to 2015 you're spending a
lot of time
on YouTube there may be some other
issues with you and also is every single
one of those videos to blame because you
know what one of the videos he watched
was Jimmy Kimmel probably Jimmy Kimmel
is to blame these interviews and data
points from a picture of a disillusioned
young man an internet savvy group of
right-wing reactionaries and a powerful
algorithm that learns to connect the two
it suggests that YouTube may have played
a role in steering mr. cane and other
young men like him toward the far-right
fringes it also suggested that in time
YouTube is capable of steering them in
very different directions
okay well now you really don't have a
point of your article right so you're
saying that YouTube could direct you to
the far right also it could direct you
to the left which means you're an
independent human with the capacity to
click on things congratulations and they
talk about that then they have a chart
it shows the number of political videos
that this guy watched each month it says
the right wing content mr. came viewed
in 2015 in 2016 often consisted of
videos by stefan molyneux with titles
like social justice warriors always lie
and the global warming hoax and then it
says mr. Kane also watched many videos
by members of the so-called intellectual
dark web that would be a group in which
I'm involved like the popular comedian
Joe Rogan and the political commentator
Dave Rubin it's Joe Rogan's fault it's
Joe's fault amazing it's amazing so he
watches a video by stefan molyneux in a
video by Joe Rogan is Joe Rogan's fault
clearly during 2017 it came began
watching more videos from left-wing
channels Oh amazing so um then why is
this a story I'm confused why is a
front-page story with a graphic of me
I'm just a little confused also I'm
confused why this guy Caleb came as an
important human because he made a video
like welcome to the world where
everybody makes videos from an early age
mr. Cain was fascinated by internet
culture says in the New York Times as a
teenager he browsed 4chan the lawless
message board okay well that would be a
pretty good indicator that the guy was
ripe for radicalization already by the
time he was a teenager 4chan is a lot
more radical than YouTube in terms of
general content he played online games
with his friends devoured videos of
intellectuals debating charged topics
like the existence of God well clearly
that's a problem the internet was an
escape mr. King grew up in
post-industrial Appalachia was raised by
his conservative Christian grandparents
he was smart but shy and socially
awkward he went to Community College but
dropped out after three semesters broke
into press he resolved to get his act
together he began looking for help in
the same place he looked for everything
YouTube one day in late 2014 YouTube
recommended a self-help video by stefan
molyneux a canadian talk show host and
self-styled philosopher mr. Molyneux who
describes himself as an
anarcho-capitalist had a political
agenda he was a men's write advocate who
said that feminism was a form of
socialism and the progressive gender
politics were holding young men back he
offered a conservative commentary on pop
culture and current events explaining
why Disney's frozen was an allegory
about female vanity or either fatal
shooting of an armed black teenager by a
white police officer was proof of the
dangers of rap culture mr. Kane was a
liberal who cared about social justice
worried about wealth inequality and
believed in climate change but he found
mr. Mallen whose diatribes fascinating
even when they disagreed and then
apparently he started watching a lot of
Molyneux videos they watched them Paul
Joseph Watson and then he watched him a
lot of videos on feminism and then he
watched some racist videos but he never
actually became racist hey this is that
this is the part that's hilarious so he
says that he never became an actual
racist he says these people weren't all
shouting demagogues they were
entertainers building their audience
with satirical skits debates and
interviews with like-minded creators
these creators were active on Facebook
and Twitter too but YouTube was their
headquarters the place where they could
earn a living by Hawking merchandise and
getting a cut of the money spent on
advertisements that accompanied their
videos and then he says that he he felt
alienated and he started being
programmed by the algorithm to watch
particular other ads that here's the
best part okay so when finally you get
to the point of all of this he has asked
whether in fact he ever turned into a
racist after watching all this stuff
quote mr. Kane never bought into the
Wright's most extreme views the far
rights most extreme views like Holocaust
denial or the need for white ethno state
still far-right ideology bled into his
daily life
he began referring to himself as a trad
con a traditional conservative committed
to old-fashioned gender norms he dated
an evangelical Christian woman and he
fought with his liberal friends it was
kind of sad said Zelda wait a friend of
Mr Cain's from high school I was just
like wow what happened how did you get
this way I love that for the New York
Times people ask questions like what
happened how did you get this way
because you date an evangelical
Christian woman and because you fight
with your liberal friends so if you're
not a liberal and you date a
conservative obviously there is
something wrong with you
and then they focus in on Molyneux a lot
I mean that this article is largely
about stefan molyneux but again i'm
confused as to why it is why it is that
this particular person is being profiled
when he was never sucked into stefan
molyneux 'he's kind of alright worldview
and then i love this in 2080 nearly four
years after mr. Cain had begun watching
right-wing YouTube videos a new kind of
video began appearing in his
recommendations these videos were made
by left-wing creators but they mimicked
the aesthetics of right-wing YouTube one
video is a debate about immigration
between miss southern Lauren southern
and Steven Bunnell a liberal youtuber
known as destiny came watch the video to
cheer on southern but mr. Pennell is a
better debater and mr. Kane reluctantly
declared him the winner mr. Kane also
found videos by Natalie win a former
academic philosopher who goes by the
name contra points miss win were
elaborate costumes into drag style
performances in which she explained why
Western culture wasn't under attack from
immigrants or why race was a social
construct and then it talks about how
wonderfully funny and engaging all of
these people are on the right and then
he says well he became left-wing oh well
so two happy stories this is a happy
story in the end and then he came out
and he said that he didn't like all of
the stuff that he had watched before and
then people were mean to him the New
York Times spends I kid you not
several thousand words on this story and
they have pictures again of Milton
Friedman and me alongside pictures of
actual alt-right racists who have spent
many years ripping hey the goal of the
New York Times story is obvious Cain's
stories not all that interesting there's
nothing there so the question is why did
the New York Times dedicate this much
space to it the reason the New York
Times dedicated this much space to it is
because this is part of a hard push by
the left in advance of the 2020 election
to silence right-wing views that's what
this is that is why they're lumping in
everybody on the right that's why they
are suggesting that YouTube's algorithm
not that people watch my videos and that
YouTube's algorithm wrongly directs them
to all right videos a proposition with
which I would generally agree but the
idea is that my videos should not be
promoted and Crowder's videos should not
be promoted and anybody else who's on
the right their videos should not be
promoted like mainstream right-wing
figures their videos should not be
promoted Jordan Peterson shouldn't be
promoted Joe Rogan's shouldn't be
promoted that's
the New York Times shutdown debate this
is from your Free Press delightful folks
and some more evidence of this in just a
second first this Father's Day give dad
a gift packed with the Omaha Steaks he
craves listen there's nothing better for
Father's Day than the meats go to Omaha
Steaks comm insert code Shapiro in the
search bar and you get 74 percent off
the Father's Day steak fix gift package
it's something that he'll truly enjoy
don't get him another pair of socks
instead get him a bucket full of meat
okay listen to this deal a $235 value
now for only $59.99 order now you get
two filet mignons to top sirloins to
pork chops for Omaha Steaks burgers for
gourmet jumbo frames for chicken-fried
steaks all beef meatballs for chicken
breast for caramel apple tartlets a
package of Omaha Steaks signature
seasoning and you get 4 extra Omaha
Steaks burgers for free he get all of
that for like $59.99 if that amazing
package is a gift for Dad or stock up
for the incredible summer grilling all
at 74% off again order now and get that
exclusive Omaha Steaks Father's Day
steak fix package valued at 235 bucks
for just $59.99 just go to Omaha Steaks
com type coach Shapiro into the search
bar don't wait the offer ends soon go to
Omaha Steaks com type Shapiro into the
search bar to get the father's day steak
fix package today I mean that is one
hell of a deal go check them out right
now I have lots of friends who've tried
Omaha Steaks they say that are the best
in the business go check them out Omaha
Steaks common tape Shapiro in to the
search bar to get that Father's Day
steak fix a package right now okay so
it's not just this New York Times piece
this asinine New York Times piece about
a guy who's a liberal but then watched a
lot of YouTube videos and considered
himself a traditional conservative until
he went back to being a mild-mannered
good liberal it's it that that's not
what the New York Times piece is about
is the evils of the right and how the
right will suck you in with their
nefarious videos on the youtubes and
really how YouTube should shut this
thing down and YouTube is already eager
to please this is true for it for all of
the tech companies YouTube is is eager
to please they are looking to avoid
scrutiny by left wingers who continue to
blame them for all of the ills in the
world and it's not just YouTube it's
also Pinterest so Pinterest is
apparently owned by Google
James O'Keefe just got a whistleblower
from Pinterest to talk about how they're
silencing particular voices on Pinterest
one of the voices that they are
silencing on Pinterest
is the is live-action and Lila Rose
according to a new project by project
Veritas this is daily wire reporting it
presents a series of accusations of
political and ideological bias against
conservatives Christians and pro lifers
behind the scenes at Pinterest a social
media platform with some 300 million
active monthly users since the report
was first released Pinterest reportedly
has taken action concerning one of the
allegations in a video that includes
testimony from a whistleblower who works
for Pinterest and whose identity is
concealed in the video O'Keefe presents
internal documents provided by the
whistleblower showing what appeared to
be various means of censoring contents
including a porn site block list that
includes live action org which is a
pro-life site run by Viola rose so in
other words if you are against abortion
they listed you on the porn site block
list so that your content could not
appear some of the other content that
was censored by the site was content
from yours truly here is James O'Keefe
talking about it in a video from Project
Veritas the Pinterest insider also saw
how quote white supremacist unquote
content like Ben Shapiro's commentary
for instance goes from identified to
censor this is if Effie Ouma or if he is
oma calling ben shapiro a white
supremacist some would say that well
that's just her giving her opinion on a
private slack board what do you say to
that so this was actually in a woman
where policy makers were making
decisions about content and there is
follow-up action made to these to these
posts what sort of actions do they take
on Shapiro content you've seen Susie
made an advisory document about this
type of content and then this advisory
content ended up in our sensitive tons
list which is content that has to be
manually entered the den affects all the
content that comes into home feeds
people's organizations okay so they are
limiting what you can get in a search
this is what the New York Times wants
from YouTube to this is what the New
York Times ones from Google is what the
New York Times wants from Pinterest this
is what the Democrats want what
Democrats would like is for all of these
various outlets to feel the pressure
from the media so strongly that they
simply start censoring conservative
content it's not just me by the way
according to the Daily wire reporting on
this project Veritas report among the
claims presented by the whistleblower is
that my content was censored in a zero
tolerance movement terms related to
Christianity are blocked from
autocomplete a video series exposing
Planned Parenthood was included in a
censor list as a harmful conspiracy and
live action org was included on a list
of porn sites blocked by the platform
meaning no links to its content could be
produced by users and then you've got
the CEO of Google who's openly coming
out and saying listen we are trying to
determine what exactly hate speeches
it's omit with what's amazing here truly
is to watch as members of the media this
is Axios on HBO right both supposed of
free speech concepts HBO used to be the
place that was totally free speech HBO
was not cable so you could curse HBO is
the place where you can see full frontal
nudity cuz no censorship we hate
censorship on that Axios on HBO is
interviewing the head of Google and
trying to get the guy to basically
establish hate speech standards that
will be used by Google to shut down
particular content there is no good
definition of hate speech that
definition simply does not exist and the
danger in trying to define hate speech
in any real way is that folks on the
Left are likely to label anything from
the right hate speech as that New York
Times piece exposed you to showed you
here is the CEO of Google though trying
to suggest that he's going to somehow
implement a standard for hate speech
that does not exist under American law
nor should it exist under American law
more recently we have introduced you
know just like today we do this in
search we you know we add rank content
based on quality and so we're bringing
that same notion and approach to YouTube
so that we can rank higher quality stuff
better and really prevent borderline
content content which doesn't exactly
violate policies which need to be the
mood but which can still cause harm and
so we are working hard it's a hard
computer science problem it's also hard
societal problem because we need better
frameworks around what is hate speech
what's not and how do we as a company
make those decisions at scale and get it
right without making mistakes okay well
you're not getting it right and you will
make mistakes
I mean this was shown last week with
YouTube banning actual historical
coverage of the Nazis because YouTube's
algorithm couldn't determine what was
historical coverage of Nazis and what
was neo-nazi content some of the most
disturbing stuff there's when they say
well you know we're gonna get rid of
borderline content or we're going to
limit borderline content so explain to
me how the Daily wire for example should
be treated as borderline content while
Huffington Post should be treated as non
borderline content you're gonna have to
explain that one to me and if you
believe that Google and YouTube and
Facebook aren't going to elevate
left-wing sources above right-wing
sources you're out of your mind of
course they are when they talk about the
authoritative sources that they like
those authoritative sources are in fact
the mainstream media outlets that are
currently pushing from limitations what
they're looking for in effect is a crony
capitalism that that is that is
effectively a business type of collusion
it's actually much closer to
monopolistic interference than it is to
free markets or free minds because
what's happening here is that the New
York Times CNN a lot of left-wing
outlets are looking at the future of the
Internet and they're concerned and
rightly so they're concerned that the
market is dissipating their influence
and so what they're doing is they're
going to the tech companies they're
saying listen we are going to attack you
incessantly we're going to attack you
incessantly as creating violence we're
going to attack you incessantly as
radicalizing people we're going to
attack you repeatedly continuously we're
gonna do this all the time until you
elevate our content and deep Enzi
platform and deal with a content that we
don't like now even if I agree with a
lot of the content being banned meaning
that I agree that some of that content
is gross I don't think that it should be
been the reason is because I don't trust
these companies to make those sorts of
decisions I trust the American people to
make these decisions and this is
astonishing to watch media outlets that
purportedly worried about Donald Trump
cracking down on freedom of the press
spending front-page space and time on
HBO trying to condemn tech platforms for
being open fora it really is an amazing
thing and they're only a couple reasons
to do it one is ideological and one is
market-based the ideological reason is
because they don't like that there are
views that they don't like that are
gaining credence and the market-based
reason is that there are all of these
other outlets that are gaining all sorts
of credibility and credence and money
and making lots of money and they are
afraid that their influence is
dissipating so they are creating a false
monopoly again with the help of the tech
companies they're going to restore the
media monopoly that existed back in the
1980s in the 1970s by using the tech
pros to shut down everybody else that's
what's going on
okay in just a second I wanna get to the
the Trump tariff plan how has that
actually created immigration policy was
a win or lose for President Trump what
actually happened there cuz it seems
like there's a lot of confusion still
first no one really has time to go to
the post office you're busy I'm busy you
know I like the post office but the fact
is last time I went there I got a
massive parking ticket because you just
don't have time you park anywhere near
the red zone they give you a ticket and
meanwhile you're inside lugging all your
mail and your packages and you're
spending an hour there it's a hassle
that's why you need stamps comments one
of the most popular time-saving tools
for small businesses stamps.com
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with discounts you can't
even get at the post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office direct
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once that mail is
ready just hanage your mail carrier or
drop it in a mailbox it is that simple
with stamps comm you get five cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps.com is a
no-brainer it saves you time and it
saves you money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses are to use stamps calm right
now my listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale with no
long-term commitment just go to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage type in a promo code
Shapiro that is stamps comm enter
Shapiro there's a reason we use it here
at the Daily wire office says it saves
me time it saves me money in my own life
it saves our company time and money as
well now can save you time and money
stamps comm click that mic at the top of
the homepage type in Shapiro okay so
we're gonna get to President Trump and
his tariffs and Mexico trying to crack
down on immigration in just one second
first you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire calm and subscribe for $9.99
a month you can you can subscribe now as
I've been discussing for weeks this is
not just an appeal because we have great
content that you can only get if you're
a subscriber you know the additional two
hours of my show the Andrew Klavan show
and the Mount wall show and if you want
it the Michael Knoll show not only do
you get all of those things and not only
if you subscribe annually do you get the
leftist here's hierarchal tumblr which
is indeed magnificent not only did you
get all of those wondrous things he
actually gets to support the principle
of free speech in America
now listen YouTube is a private company
they can do what they want Google is a
private company they can do what they
want but what they are moving toward is
the censorship and curbing of your
ability to access the programs that you
love and the best way for you to support
us and ensure that our message is still
gonna reach people is to subscribe to
help support our show the fact is the
left is hell-bent on destroying the
market for any conservative show not
only by depriving us of access on their
platforms as you see from this Pinterest
story not only by doing that sort of
stuff but also by going after our
advertisers we have wonderful
advertisers on the program what the left
does is targets those advertisers and
then tries to drive them off the program
trying to drive down our ability to make
a profit and to pay our workers so that
we can't produce our show anymore
they've tried to do this with Laura
Ingram and Tucker Carlson and Sean
Hannity they do it all the time the best
way to avoid that please go subscribe
over at Daly wired I can't become part
of the team and it really is being part
of the team you are helping out the team
if you want conservative messages to be
promulgated if you want young people to
hear those messages you should go and
subscribe right now if you wanna be able
to get that content you should subscribe
right now go check us out we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all ready so now the latest on President
Trump and his tariffs push on Mexico so
late last week I gave credit on the show
to president Trump because there are a
bunch of reports the president Trump was
going to be able to leverage a
significant concession from the Mexican
government that significant concession
was a safe third country provision so
the United States has what's called a
safe third country deal with the
Canadian government what that safe third
country deal does it says that if
somebody is trying to escape a human
rights abusing country and they want to
get out and they go to Canada they have
to apply for asylum in Canada the first
country that they leave the first
country that they reach rather is the
country where they have to apply for
asylum so you can't go to Canada and
then apply to asylum in the United
States because then it really is more
just you want to come to the United
States it really isn't about you
applying for asylum we have a safe third
country provision with Canada well we'd
like one of those with Mexico and there
was talk last week late last week like
Thursday night but the Mexican
government was going to give us one that
finally we were going to get into Old
Mexico where if people entered Mexico
from Guatemala or El Salvador that
people would first have to apply for
asylum in Mexico before they could apply
to enter the United States and president
Trump's tariffs were given credit for
that and President Trump came online on
Friday and he said that the tariffs
would not go into effect because he made
some sort of deal with Mexico so we have
a bunch of conflicting reports on this
what exactly the Mexican government gave
up did they give up anything
did they make concessions six months ago
and then basically Trump's people sold
that to him as new concessions to avoid
the tariffs all of this is eminently
unclear so the Washington Post has a
piece today called hell Mexico talked
Trump out of tariff threat with
immigration crackdown pact as Mexican
negotiators persuaded President Trump to
back down from his tariff threat by
agreeing to an unprecedented crackdown
on Central American migrants and
accepting more expansive measures in
Mexico if the initial efforts don't
deliver quick results according to
officials from both governments and
documents reviewed by The Washington
Post the enforcement measures Mexico has
promised include the deployment of a
militarized national guard at the
Guatemalan border thousands of
additional migrant arrests per week and
the acceptance of bus loads of asylum
seekers turned away from the United
States border daily all geared toward
cutting the migrant flow sharply in
coming weeks the measures described by
officials from both sides and included
in Mexican
shading documents reviewed by the post
appear to be more substantial than what
the Mexican government has attempted
thus far
during the precipitous rise in migration
to the United States border since
heralding the packed in a Friday night
tweet Trump has fumed at criticism that
he capitulated to Mexico and that is a
quart amounts to a series have
previously agreed to measures Trump
officials on Monday described the Accord
as a breakthrough the president
considered Mexico's plan aggressive
enough to suspend his tariff threat even
though he liked the idea of imposing the
duties over the house from members of
his own party US officials say they were
particularly impressed with Mexico's
pledge to play up to 6000 National Guard
troops to its border region with
Guatemala Mexico described its plan to
US officials as the first time in recent
history that Mexico has decided to take
operational control of its southern
border as a priority according to
Mexican government documents such
language amounted to the kind of
rhetorical shift Trump officials were
looking for from the leftist government
of President Honduras Manuel Lopez
Obrador who last year dismissed migrants
enforcement in Mexico as dirty work at
the behest of the United States Trump
said Monday his zeal with Mexico was
fully signed and documented and has
provisions that have not yet been fully
disclosed on Monday afternoon at the
White House Trump said that the
agreement has been locked in and will be
announced very soon
most asylum seekers who reached the US
are now processed and released into the
United States
interior Mexico has repeatedly said it
will not agree to a safe third country
Accord that would require it to take in
us-bound asylum seekers transistor it's
to transiting its territory but Mexican
officials have been willing to negotiate
something that would function similarly
if responsibility for asylum seekers
were shared among others in the region
they say Asylum changes would require
approval from the Mexican lawmakers
Trump said in a tweet Monday he will
impose tariffs if the regional Asylum
overhaul does not pass so it is not
clear at this point
what exactly is in place and what
exactly is not in place however if a
safe third country provision ends up
being enforced and it was done so
because President Trump threatened
tariffs then good for President Trump my
fear was the president from simply
wanted to use tariffs on Mexico because
he likes tariffs not because he actually
hoped to achieve an immigration
breakthrough if he achieves the
immigration breakthrough well then he
gets credit and that was a hundred
percent wrong and I'm more than happy to
admit it I like being wrong when it's
good for the country however there is a
your controversy there mixed messages
being sent the New York Times reports
the Mexican Foreign Minister said on
Monday and no secret immigration deal
existed between his country and the
United States directly contradicting
president Trump's claim on Twitter that
a fully signed and documented agreement
would soon be revealed when a second
I'll explain how this controversy is
continuing to unfold
Marcelo Abroad Mexico's top diplomat
said at a news conference in Mexico City
there was an understanding that both
sides would evaluate the flow of
migrants in the coming months if the
number of migrants crossing the US
border is not significantly reduced he
said both sides of agreed spur new
discussions about more aggressive
changes to regional asylum rules that
could have a bigger impact a Briard said
let's have a deadline to see what what
we have works if not we'll sit down look
at the measures you proposed and that we
propose the public statement served as
an official response to several days of
tweeting by mr. Trump who is reacted
angrily to the suggestion that he would
through his threats of tariffs on all
Mexican goods in exchange for a week
deal on immigration now as I say I don't
want these tariffs to go into effect
they are very bad for the economy
they're very bad for Trump by the way if
the economy tanks he has no shot at
reelection I think that the tariffs
generally are bad idea if however the
tariffs were useful in leveraging a good
immigration deal out of the Mexican
government good but now the Mexican
government seems to be waffling so it is
unclear at this point what if anything
has been signed
there's been no public no public
documentation put forth at this point
there's a us-mexico joint declaration
that Trump announced with fanfare on
Friday it mentioned further public
action it said that the countries agreed
to continue their discussion on the
terms of additional understandings to
address irregular migrant flows and
Asylum issues to be completed and
announced within 90 days American
official said on Monday Trump appeared
to be referring to an agreement in
principle to revisit the migration
situation in 45 days and again in 90
days there was apparently significant
disagreement on Monday between the
Mexican government and American
officials about what the negotiators
actually agreed to regarding further
action so as I said I will
when President Trump achieves an actual
victory here that is documental I will
give him 100% credit as it stands this
looks a lot like when President Trump
was in North Korea and President Trump
was suggesting over and over again that
he had reached some sort of breakthrough
with Kim Jong
and then turned out not to be true so I
think that we can trust but verify
so sure happy to give President Trump
credit on a breakthrough now we'll have
to verify do the migrations go down is a
safe third country provision in the
works will any of this stuff actually
happen Trump didn't specifically
mentioned the safe third country
provision on Monday but he said they
would have an agreement they would
announce very soon it's all done that is
not what was described by the foreign
minister for Mexico a Burrard said they
will propose a safe third country we
said it will have to be with UN Human
Rights Council and it will have to be
regional he said Mexico preferred a
regional Asylum agreement that would
review the flow of migrants across
Mexico and Central America with a number
of countries including Panama and Brazil
so I think this whole thing is still in
flux is the bottom line now the good
news is that President Trump can snap
back those tariffs pretty much any time
he wants so there's a pretty strong
incentive for the Mexican government not
exactly to screw around with President
Trump but maybe if they apply its laid
tactic maybe if they delay this thing
all the way until next year they hope
that a Democrat will be elected at which
point open immigration begins again I
will say that president from strategic
use of tariffs with regard to China has
not been the has not been exactly the
serious problem that I think everyone
thought that it was going to be now it
has been a serious problem in terms of
the economy the economy is more brittle
growth is slowing all of that is true
but the amount of Chinese leverage that
they are willing to apply at this point
does not appear to be all that high my
China does have more to lose than the
United States and as I've said before
there is a case to be made that the
Chinese government ought to be pressured
in the way the Mexican government is not
pressured the Mexican government should
be pressured to stop the migrant flow
but the Mexican government is not an
open adversary of the United States
China really is and the good news is
that China's attempts at leveraging the
United States are so far a giant fail
there's an article in The Washington
Post talking about how China's hints
that it will choke off rare earths
access in the United States is not in
fact that easy David Lynch writing for
The Washington Post
he says China dominates the global
market for rare earths materials and has
been threatening to take them hostage in
the deepening trade conflict just the
suggestion that Beijing could starve
American factories of essential
materials has sent rare-earth prices
soaring over the past month with this
prose
oxide used in lasers and nuclear reactor
control rods up by one-third but the
alarm overlooks the rise over the past
decade of alternative sources of rare
earths and ignores the difficulties
China would face and implementing a ban
including the prospect of widespread
smuggling and the likelihood of hurting
countries the Chinese authorities may
prefer not to alienate so president
Trump has been applying leverage to
China and his right to do so will see
how the Mexican negotiation which I'm
more skeptical of plays out and I'm
hoping that the president's strategy
there pays off and that we see some real
gains here I will say that the media
obviously the media obviously are
jumping to the conclusion that Trump has
got nothing in exchange for backing down
from his tariff threats you have
Anderson Cooper the very objective
journalist on CNN not waiting to see but
instead jumping in and saying that this
was all about nothing their story says
and I'm quoting now the lead the deal to
avert tariffs that President Trump
announced with great fanfare on Friday
night consists largely of actions that
Mexico had already promised to take in
Prior discussions with the US over the
past several months according to
officials from both countries who are
familiar with the negotiations in other
words whatever might be coming down the
pike when it comes to what is already
transpired all the drama all the talks
all the threats of what amounts to
waging economic warfare on a major
trading partner and Ally we're all about
nothing okay well maybe they were and
maybe they weren't we don't know yet is
sort of the issue so I think that trumps
the adversaries are going to declare
that this is a big loss for Trump but
honestly where's the big loss for Trump
exactly so he threatened tariffs the
tariffs didn't go into place that seems
like a win for US citizens I mean
tariffs are attacks on us and maybe he
gets something out of this maybe he
doesn't we will find out soon enough
but everybody's sort of jumping to a
conclusion I think is is doing just that
jumping to a conclusion well meanwhile
Democrats hosted John Dean ena on
Capitol Hill yesterday this is an
absurdity is an absurdity so Democrats
decided they would host John Dean who is
a partisan hack on Capitol Hill and it
didn't go great for him basically he's a
he has suggested that every Republican
president since Richard Nixon is in fact
Richard Nixon who's the former White
House Counsel to President Nixon who was
involved in Watergate and he suggested
that President Trump is not mentally
wealth and mentally
to serve here is him suggesting that
Trump can't be President the last time I
appeared before your committee was July
11 1974 during the impeachment inquiry
of Richard Nixon clearly I'm not here
today as a fact witness I accepted the
invitation to come here today because I
hope I can give a little historical
perspective on the Muller report in many
ways the Muller report is to President
Trump but the so called Watergate
roadmap was to President Richard Nixon
State a little differently special
counsel Muller has provided this
committee with a roadmap okay really you
can tell the Democrats are desperate
when they're calling in John Dean if you
call in John Dean the guy from 1974 who
called President Bush a Watergate style
president if you're inviting that guy
and that's the best you can do I would
recommend that you guys get some better
candidates because if you're relying on
John Dean to take down the president you
may be in serious trouble okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like over
the weekend write a terrific book by
Alan Greenspan called capitalism in
America a history alone with Adrian
Wooldridge it is a really readable easy
history of the economics of the United
States it talks about the u.s. is free
market economy it talks about how FDR
changed that free market economy it
talks about the relative growth rates in
the US economy over time it talks about
everything from free trade to monetary
policy and it is very readable okay it
is not a hard book to read so go check
it out capitalism in America by alan
greenspan who's a devotee of milton
friedman among others who apparently
apparently was no ivan told by the new
york times milton friedman was basically
an alt writer but alan greenspan was one
of his was one of his acolytes and of
course ran the fed check it out
capitalism in america by alan greenspan
and Adrian Wooldridge definitely worth
the watch okay other things that I like
today so let's see okay well let's say
you know what let's get to a bunch of
things that I hate because there's a lot
to hate today so let's do it
well I will say that I sort of like and
hate this a feminist Sophie Lewis is now
admitting that abortion is a killing she
just said it's the sort of killing that
we like which at least is definitely
honest I mean that's good I wonder if
she will be censored on Pinterest the
same way that Lila Rosen live action
have been here she is explaining that
abortion is a form of killing but it's a
good form of killing you know like the
kind of killing of like people that we
don't like that kind of killing abortion
is in my opinion and I recognize how
controversial this is a form of killing
it is a form of killing that we need to
be able to defend I am NOT interested in
where a human life starts to exist
I see the forms of making and unmaking
each other as sort of continuous
processes okay I see the forms of making
and unmaking each other as a continuous
process that seems like that's a that's
pretty much for Jack the Ripper had to
say about prostitutes right there the
forms of making and unmaking each other
it's a continuous process you know when
I gut this prostitute over here that's
pretty much I understood making her
random here we're all making and
unmaking each other all the time aren't
we I mean really is that such a big deal
just unmade her intestines I mean that's
like but they're making themselves and
you're making them and I make I mean
like okay well at least she's honest
points for honesty to abortion lady it's
a form of killing she likes that is a
case that I can at least understand so
well done there that's good stuff okay
other things that I hate today so there
are two pieces one from the New York
Times and one from the Washington Post
one is from a Capote kind of
conservative
Henry Olsen and one is from a person
named Aaron Aaron Bustani this one I
particularly like from Aaron Bustani the
title of the piece from the New York
Times the world is a mess
we need fully automated luxury communism
hmm
now I'm puzzled by the title I will I
will fully acknowledge I find this
puzzling because those words do not make
sense that is it that is like saying
what we truly need is a red blue green
blue grass don't know what it means
that's a sentence technically a sentence
not words that make sense in order we
need a fully automated luxury communism
we need our strategy dead but do we get
communism Thank You Aaron Bassani so
what exactly did the stupid article say
it says it starts with a burger in 2008
a Dutch professor named Mark post
presented the proof of concept for what
he called cultured meat 5 years later in
a London TV studio mr. post and his
colleagues ate a burger they had grown
from animal cells in a laboratory
secretly funded by Sergey Brin a
co-founder of Google
the journey from petri dish to plate had
cost $325,000 making they're the most
expensive meal in history fortunately
the results were promising honey root
cellar a nutrition scientist concluded
the patty was close to me but not not as
juicy the next question was whether this
breakthrough could be made cheaper much
cheaper the first cultured beef burgers
are likely to enter the market next year
at approximately 50 bucks each but that
won't last long
within a decade they will probably be
more affordable than even the cheapest
barbecue staples of today offer a
product that uses fewer resources
produces negligible greenhouse gases and
remarkably requires no animals to die so
far this is a pretty stirring
representation of how awesome capitalism
isn't it is isn't it and they're talking
about how private funding created a
burger that will be cheaper than regular
burgers and also have many of the
non-void many of the side effects of
burgers so there's pretty good case for
capitalism I remember there's an article
about communism wait it's not just
barbecues and burgers last year just a
leader in cellular agriculture cut a
deal to start producing one of the
world's tastiest steak swag you a
company called endless West which also
makes grape las' wine has started to
produce cliff the world's first
molecular whisky luxury could be coming
to all the case of cultured food and
drink fire from a curiosity is a
template for a better freer and more
affluent world world where we provide
for the needs of everyone in style but
how do we get there
to say that well I mean I think that we
just explained how we got there didn't
we I mean we're not the first few
paragraphs all about how all these
private companies are creating awesome
new stuff that will become insanely
cheap because of the free market so I
think you sort of answered it we could
just stop the article there but no we
still got 600 words to fill so according
to this genius columnist Aaron Bustani
so he says how do we get there to say
the present here is one of crisis
borders on cliche it differs from the
dystopias of George Orwell or Aldous
or hell in the paintings of Hieronymous
Bosch it is unlike Europe during the
Black Death or Central Asia as it faced
the galloping Golden Horde and yet it is
true ours is an age of crisis I swear
this was written by a high school junior
getting a C and like to say it differs
from other dystopias and then let me
show you how many books I've read all
from my high school English class George
Orwell and Aldous Huxley also I've heard
of the Black Death guys he says we
inhabit a world of low growth low
productivity and low wages
well not low wages okay then that is not
true low productivity historically
speaking and not even close to drew low
growth is kind of true and that's mostly
because of government intervention ISM
is a world where billions mostly in the
global south live in poverty
a world defined by inequality actually
the world is defined by a massive
reduction in the amounts of inequality
between the poorest and everybody else
considering that 80% of the global
extreme poor have been lifted out of
global extreme poverty since 1980 by
capitalism but remember there's an
article about communism the most
pressing crisis of all arguably is an
absence of collective imagination yes
that is arguable that isn't that is an
arguable contention that the biggest
crisis is an absence of collective
imagination if I'm gonna go with like
biggest biggest crisis I would say let's
see collapse of traditional morality
might be up there probably the crisis in
Syria the slaughter of hundreds of
thousands of people that's a maybe
disease and poverty in Africa there are
a few failure of collective imagine
whenever people talk about collective
imagination understand what they really
mean by collective imagination is one
person at the head of a massive
government who imposes their ideas on
everybody else because you know what is
the collective imagination the free
market that is the collective
imagination it's all of our individual
imaginations but in a market collective
imagination is where there's somebody at
the top bossing people around the term
collective imagination in fact is
somewhat self-defeating because
imagination is by nature individual now
we can work in groups and toss ideas
back and forth to each other but the
idea of a collective imagination a hive
mind so to speak the reason that a hive
mind doesn't really work that way is
because they hive is subservient to the
queen bee but this columnist says it as
as if humanity has been a flip
by a psychological complex in which we
believe the president world is stronger
than our capacity to remake it as if the
very essence of humanity if there is
such a thing is not to constantly build
new world this is this is such bad
writing my goodness if we can move
beyond such a failure we will be able to
see something wonderful the plummeting
cost of information and advances in
technology are providing the ground for
a collective future of freedom and
luxury for all automation robotics and
machine learning will as many August
bodies from Bank of England to the White
House have predicted substantially
shrink the workforce creating widespread
technological unemployment
but that's only a problem if you think
work is something to be cherished from
any work is drudgery an automation could
set us free from it okay well from any
it's not so that's a problem but also
you're gonna have to give people
something to do and it turns out the
communism doesn't give anything for
people to do they sit there and they
take things gene-editing this is one of
the funny things about people who
promote socialism and communism there's
this weird idea that if you promote
socialism you promote communism that
what will spring free is a bunch of
itinerant poets who sit around writing
about the beautiful flowers and creating
a world of art I remember that Nancy
Pelosi said this about so-called job at
Locke and she said that people were
locked into their jobs for health care
and that was a bad thing we needed to
disconnect health care from your job by
presumably nationalizing it so that you
could write poetry now I know a lot of
people without jobs very few of them
except for producer Nick here actually
sit around writing poetry or going and
learning to mine for gold a very few of
them most people who are unemployed are
pretty depressed and pretty unhappy cuz
they don't have a lot of stuff to do but
this article continues by talking about
how as we make things more and more
prosperous well now we can try communism
he says I love that she says the
consequences are far-reaching and
potentially transformative of the of the
increasing technological imagine
technological achievements of man for
the crises that confront our world today
technological unemployment global
poverty societal age and climate change
resource scarcity we can already glimpse
the remedy but there's a catch it's
called capitalism it has created the
newly emerging abundance but it is
unable to share around the fruits of
technological development okay if you
really believe that capitalism has been
unable to share around the fruits of
technological development I ask you how
many people in the United States have
cell phones
I ask you how many people in the United
States of microwaves and cars everybody
takes this stuff for granted because of
capitalism communism creates nothing
communism redistributes what is there
until it kills off the golden the goose
that creates the golden eggs he says a
system where things are produced only
for profit capitalism seeks to ration
resources to ensure returns no that's
not how capitalism works it capitalism
works through competition free markets
work through competition just like
today's companies of the futures were
for monopolies and seek rents the
results will be imposed scarcity when
there's not enough food health care or
energy to go around okay this has not
been the history of capitalism the only
enforced monopolies are ones that are
enforced by the government government
monopolies are monopolies monopolies too
and result in far more scarcity than
free market economics but according to
this columnist we have to go beyond
capitalism many will find the suggestion
unwholesome to them the claim that
capitalism will or should end is like
saying a triangle doesn't have three
sides so that the law of gravity no
longer applies well an Apple falls from
a tree but for a better world it is an
imperative
we can see the contours of something new
a society is distinct from our own as
that of 20th century from feudalism or
urban civilization from the life of the
hunter-gatherer it builds on
technologies whose development has been
accelerating for decades to grasp it
will require a new politics fully
automated luxury communism what the hell
does that even mean we've gone through
the entire article I still don't
understand we're fully automated luxury
communism means it doesn't mean anything
all it means is that capitalism is
awesome but you like communism so you're
gonna say communism over and over well
done New York Times
my goodness if your case for communism
is basically the technology is gonna
solve all of our problems you just made
the unwitting case for capitalism thank
you very much now on the right you're
seeing some folks who are making an
unwitting case against capitalism or a
winning case one of those people is
Henri Olsen so Henri Olsen is a really
interesting commentator he comes from
sort of the tucker carlson conservative
school of thought that suggests that
free markets are the problem hit a piece
in The Washington Post called
conservative elites love to defend
market orthodoxy don't fall for it
well I love that everybody who disagrees
with Henry Olson is now an elite you
know it like I believe that just in
terms of probably income and education
it's fair to say I'm an elite in terms
of my
opinion on politics I am NOT an elitist
I've always made this distinction I've
never understood this this sort of
connection between quote/unquote elites
and elitists and Ronald Reagan was an
elite he was not an elitist Donald Trump
is an elite he is not an elitist and
elitist as somebody who believes they
should run the world for everybody else
that is the opposite of free-market
libertarianism which suggests that you
should make your own choices without the
government cramming down choices and
subsidies upon you anyway
Henry Olson says there's been a debate
brewing within the world of conservatism
ever since Donald Trump won the GOP
nomination some on the right bitterly
opposed his divergence from Republican
economic orthodoxy and are fighting to
defend the role of economic markets in
society against what they perceive as
attacks from other conservatives these
elites may be right to be afraid but
that's because at heart they are more
libertarian than they are conservative I
think you and I are defining
conservative differently than because it
turns out that conservative is about
conserving the liberties guaranteed by
the Constitution of the United States
many of those liberties are tied in to
the free market such libertarian minds
and opinion leaders have criticized
Trump's call to rule out reform for
Social Security and Medicare they
ignored his calls to dramatically
increase spending on infrastructure they
savaged his views on trade trumps
overwhelming victory in the primaries
should have shocked them out of their
ideological slumber instead they're like
the French Bourbon monarchs who upon
being restored to the throne remembered
nothing and forgot nothing about the
reasons they were overthrown in the
first place hey Donald Trump and then in
the name checks may write he suggests
that Fox News television host Tucker
Carlson's rather mundane point that
today's global economy contributes in
part to the economic and social decline
in many parts of the United States was
scorned by leading lights such as David
French and ben shapiro
right we talked about it on the show
because my point was that the moral
failings of the United States are far
more linked to the moral history of the
United States in the 1960s than they are
to the fact that you can get a cheaper
product from China like I don't think
people are failing to get married
because we signed NAFTA I think people
are failing to get married because our
society has disdained marriage for
generations the marriage rates started
to decline far before the effect of
so-called kind of trade imbalances began
to be felt I mean marriage rates in the
United States started to decline in the
60s when the economy was still pretty
good now what's hilarious and by the way
the economy is still pretty good I mean
we have an all-time low unemployment
rate
now but according to Henry Olsen here's
here's where we get to the point when I
say that the left is pushing for
communism but they're really in favor of
capitalism like that article from the
New York Times and then you have people
on the right who are pushing for
government involvement in the name of
conservatism
that's Henry Olson this is fascinating
he says this my libertarian oriented
friends will not want to hear this but
we live in the garden at Franklin Delano
Roosevelt made now this should be an
athame to conservatives if somebody
comes to and they say you know we just
have to accept the new form of
government that FDR brought about FDR
was about as close to a socialist
dictator in the United States as we had
except for maybe Woodrow Wilson as we've
had in the United States he wasn't able
to get all of his plans through but the
the National Recovery Act was a fascist
piece of legislation in which the
government overtly gave a stamp of
approval to particular businesses that
abided by the government's dick tots
FDR's meddling with the economy
lengthened the Great Depression by eight
years minimum
FDR led to the second grade there are
two great depressions basically there
was one that was from that 29 to 33 and
then there was one that kicked in again
from 37 to basically World War two FDR's
economic policy was disastrous and he
created all of the economic
unsustainability that we have seen he
created the the roots of the Union
system that destroyed America's car
industry he created the the roots of the
Social Security system that is
bankrupting us in the future and
Medicaid and Medicare systems that are
comprised now 66 percent of the federal
budget so when you hear conservatives
say something like we live in the garden
that FDR made the conservative task is
to prune that garden so that the tree of
liberty can co-exist within its plan and
perhaps take up an ever larger part I
mean that's an amazing amazing statement
if you're a conservative and you believe
that your role is basically to conserve
FDR I don't think that's particularly
conservative you can make the argument
that that's what should be done on a
practical policy level because you can't
get through a more libertarian program
that I understand but if your argument
is that FDR's basic economic structure
in which he derided malefactors of great
wealth regulated the banking industry
debase the currency and did all sorts of
other things to undermine the
fundamental free market nature of
America's economy that that was a good
thing and that we have to maintain that
I don't know how that's that strikes a
chord with anybody who believes in the
Constitution of the United States or the
economic philosophy that created the
grat the great majority of America's
wealth already well that was a lot but
we will be back here tomorrow or later
today if you want to more hours of
contents you're listening to the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
president Trump wins big on his deal
with Mexico of course the mainstream
media don't give him credit for it we
will examine what is really in the deal
then another social media platform bans
conservatives and masterpiece cake shop
owner Jack Phillips gets sued for a
third time by radical leftists all that
and more at the Michael Nolt show